not that aaron rodgers watches this show
but aaron if you're watching this
morning you probably should turn the
channel now because we are going to
spend time talking about what could have
been for you
and what is for plenty of other
quarterbacks who unlike you
actually got help
in
the draft and if you're looking at the
tv screen and of course you are now
because we're no longer on radio
although we are on sirius xm211 so it
still applies to a certain extent those
are the first round receivers drafted
this year and the draft for now chris
the quarterbacks who got the most help
by way of the 2020 draft you've got the
trivia question for me which means i'll
get it wrong you'll get the first pick
let's just go ahead and play it out and
see if i'm right at least i'll have
something right this morning
okay well let's see how you do all right
here we go which qb
has the most career td passes
to first-round picks and just while you
stew on that and think this says it all
you know how many touchdown passes aaron
rodgers has the first round picks
one one to mercedes-lewis a tight end
that is it which i mean are we talking
about all time all time all the time all
the time joe montana one of them joe
montana
i was going to give you a clue when you
just you got to jump the show you're
going mr nolan
it's jerry
peyton manning through 90 zillion
touchdowns the marvin harrison and
reggie wayne they're both first-round
picks you lost and and demaryius thomas
and demarius thomas exactly right so he
threw
293 touchdown passes
to first round picks which is remarkable
really when you really think about it
that way um was dallas car club first
round quick i'm just trying to wait
yeah what was the hint going to be his
forehead's as big as mine i i don't know
what was it what was the hand i was
going to say it's one of the greatest
quarterbacks of all time just to let you
sit there like i was going to say joe
montana i know probably yes so you lose
i win i like it to me this is an easy
this is an easy one right off the bat uh
i'm gonna go with drew locke i mean how
can i not i mean drew locke for what the
denver broncos did in the first two
rounds of the draft i mean first off we
know there was some talent there on that
denver offense already we were excited
about but when you had jerry judy and kj
hamler who i look at kj hamler and
thought i mean he was the number four
receiver in the draft for me mike i know
i'm not like johnny draft expert all the
time but i'm pretty damn good and i've
been around a lot of good receivers i'm
still trying to find someone to tell me
the difference between hollywood brown
it was a first round pick and kj handler
and why he was a second round pick now i
think there were some injury issues
there issues there but
i just look at those two weapons and go
wow instant contributors instant like
gonna put fear into defenses right away
along with the weapons they already have
so i'm very excited about what they're
doing in denver right now
yeah and they even added another
receiver in round seven i believe tyree
cleveland from florida so three
receivers for the denver broncos
and they already have cortland sutton
well it's tight end
right yeah
right so he's he was one of the the the
combine freaks so you look at that you
go wow there's some potential there for
that broncos offense
uh i'm gonna go with your guy josh allen
in part because
the first round pick the fifth round
pick and the sixth round pick became
stefan diggs and then on top of that
brandon bean drafted two other receivers
gabriel davis and another guy late in
the uh in the process but they're doing
what they can to beef up the offense and
you throw in zack moss the running back
who had 388 receiving yards last year at
utah who becomes the compliment to devon
singletary you are helping
your quarterback you know aaron rodgers
got a running back but he's not really a
a pass catching running back he's not
going to diversify the passing game he's
more about building a san francisco
style running game in green bay
josh allen got three receivers and a
running back who had 388 receiving yards
last year at utah and i think the bills
have done a lot to help push that
offense toward what it was like back
when jim kelly was the quarterback
yeah well you know again i mean hey you
know me i'm one of the uh the the band
leaders or one of the you know get on
the bandwagon for the buffalo bills i i
love josh allen you know that and i love
what sean mcdermott and brandon bean are
doing with that football team they have
a plan every year they're building
something to be sustainable and be
competitive in the nfl so uh i'm with
you there was some some good things
there in the draft you know i i'm i'm
the more i look at this i go man this
list is a little longer than than i
thought it was going to be as far as
guys i could possibly draft here you
know i think here
i'm going to go
with jimmy garoppolo all right and i
know it's really only two guys but a
little along the same lines you just
talked about i mean they got
a big time receiver and brandon nyu who
i think everybody was looking at he's
going to get drafted somewhere between
20 and 32 and we heard john lynch and
kyle shanahan yeah i think they were
realistically thinking if if he was on
the board of 13 and they didn't like
anybody else i don't think they were
afraid to take iuk at 13. that's how
special shania thought he was but then
we have to add in the factor of day two
getting trent williams uh and trading
away draft picks trent williams is a
hall of fame left tackle i mean he is
big time that was already one of the
best offensive lines in football and
it's just rare you can say hey our
retiring hall of fame left tackle joe
staley just left
what we're gonna be better this year on
that position with another hall of fame
left tackle and trent williams so not
necessarily like great depth as far as
helping jimmy garoppolo out but if you
gave me two guys to
maximize their importance to an offense
in year one i would think 49ers and
those moves will be right up there with
anybody
yeah i agree with you on that and look
they already have an incredibly great
running game and they didn't have to use
the passing game as much as they needed
to or wanted to or could have in the
postseason uh they need to take that
next level though they need to have a
passing game that they can rely upon in
a big spot like that's right with the
super bowl on the line all right next
one for me and this one is close i'm
going to go philip rivers though in
indianapolis because they added they
didn't have a first round pick they
added michael pittman who they're
already comparison comparing to vincent
jackson and i hate those comparisons
because it puts too much pressure on a
guy but still michael pittman the son of
your former buccaneers teammate michael
pittman now uh one of the top receivers
to go along with ty hilton in
indianapolis and and i keep i think i've
picked
up the the the wisconsin running back i
picked him so many times this week i
forget his name jonathan donovan
jonathan taylor uh i you know that that
if you if you can pump up the running
game dramatically that helps the passing
game and jonathan taylor one of the best
running backs in the draft so between
pittman and taylor the colts have given
philip rivers some help he needs to get
the weapons around him to get the most
out of that one year and probably only
one year with the colts
yeah well they're they're you know
that's ballard you know we talked about
it a little earlier when we were talking
about the afc south he got two
first-round picks in the early second
round i mean he really did michael
pittman jr the great thing about him is
he'll be ready day one nfl ready
physical tough you know it's going to be
a receiver that philip rivers has always
liked those bigger receivers who can
throw the ball up to and michael
pittman's physical will do that and mike
you know i love jonathan taylor i
thought he was the second best running
back in the draft and he's a perfect fit
for the offense that the indianapolis
colts run
all right two rounds down chris has drew
lock and jimmy garoppolo i've got josh
allen and philip rivers quarterbacks you
got the most help in the 2020 draft
chris you're on the clock
well i'm going uh to my old buddy john
gruden in the las vegas raiders because
derek carr got some help hey they needed
to do this i mean you know again we can
say what we want about derek carr and
you know wonder how long his future is
with the las vegas raiders and yeah i'm
not so sure the personality message
meshes with a guy like john gruden but i
also can sit here and honestly say they
haven't put enough talent around him to
really know how good he could possibly
be either and i think that's a very real
aspect of this and man with henry ruggs
iii you know as the first wide receiver
off the board speed speed kills as they
say in the nfl that was a great draft
pick they need somebody like that and i
think it's a good combination with their
physical o-line and run game that they
have which is one of the better ones in
football but then you get a guy like
lynn bowden the quarterback out of
kentucky he'll be a wide receiver i mean
he's like a randall cobb-ish type player
i think he'll be really effective work
in the middle of the field and then the
other hidden gem they got brian edwards
from south carolina kind of a bigger
receiver can do it all i mean one of
those again the guys that was a little
bit down the line as far as big time
names in the draft process but big body
can beat you over the top with speed can
catch 50 50 balls so i thought they did
a really good job of finding three good
picks at the wide receiver position that
are going to help their team out pretty
pretty soon
all right i'm torn here between three
different quarterbacks i'm gonna go with
the mvp not the super bowl mvp the
league mvp in lamar jackson because of
how much he runs the jk dobbins edition
plus
devin duvernay from yeah your school in
texas the 439 40. they had hollywood
brown and myles boykin they drafted last
year they throw duvernay on top of that
they have dobbins to go with mark ingram
makes it a heck of a lot easier from
lamar jackson to keep doing exactly what
he's been doing and you've got this guy
now in dobbins who can really blossom
into the guy
whenever ingram is done and you can
extend ingram's career along the way i
just think that that they are
continuously looking for ways to go next
level with that offense in baltimore and
i think those two guys show us that they
are not going to get complacent chris
no i mean they they added offensive
linemen too i mean we know that's a huge
part of their game plan and approach
you know they got an eye for that
position and collecting big people but
yeah mike that's who i was kind of stuck
with in my last pick was raiders and
derek carr lamar jackson and the ravens
you know jk dominance is just he's he's
he's matt breida as far as straightaway
speed except he has power and durability
and then devin duvernay in a lot of ways
reminded me of debo samuel i mean you
got hollywood brown going deep and a a
big running back type wide receiver in
duberne going over the middle with that
run game that is a great formula the
ravens have created there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports